Okay. What I'd like you to do is implement the
functions gets and cas. I'm in the file with our toy
memcached. We've got our other functions set, get, delete. And cache
is just a dictionary, which, whose behavior mimics memcached for the
most part. What I'd like you to do is implement gets
and cas. So, gets takes one parameter called key, and it
returns a tuple of the value stored in the cache and
a hash to that value. A simple hash we can use,
is you can use the built-in Python function hash on
the built-in function called repr on the value. Repr turns
any Python object into a string representation of it, which
will work for our little test case here. And hash just
returns a simple hash of that, of that string. And
if the value is not in the cache, you just
return none. Now, cas is the more complicated function. This
sets the key to equal value in our cache, and return
true if the cas unique matches the hash of the value that's
already in the cache. If the cas unique does not match the
hash we don't set anything and we return false. If you look
down here, we've got our test functions. The top few are the
same ones before and down here you can see what we've, what,
what we've got. So, here's setting x to two. And then we
print gets x and this is going to print two and then a
hash. It's not going to print the word hash. It's going to print a number.
And then we're going to call cas try to set x
to three. And in this case, I'm going to send in just
zero, which I know won't be the hash and the cache
would return false. And then if we run cas again with
the correct hash, the one that was returned from gets, we
should update the cache and return true. And if we print,
get x, we should see the value of four, because that's
what we set it to here. Okay, good luck with this.